top 12 best in the history of America's
Got Talent the best talent in the
history of this show Yeah right he's
right
he really is I'll tell you you know I've
been sort of thinking about this all
week you know it is so close this time
around last year I think how he will
attest to this we kind of had a feeling
who would be the top two or three
anything can happen and and the acts are
all so talented the level of talent is
so high that I think we're going to have
tons of surprises and no prediction is
safe and the first time America seems to
be on board I mean our voting is through
the roof we are setting records Mel
wants to say something you are very
excited today again I love it you had
too much coffee have you had coffee
don't have a long wait I've had a mixed
I've had a lot of comedy short oh I mean
I'll kiss it did it I don't want to talk
about that anymore can we move on from
the kiss know about the wait you see do
you see what I'm gonna give you tonight
I will take a step further
oh you're gonna be bent over you're
gonna be bent over your head I'm gonna
pound your head into the darkest second
base ah okay my mind could be awesome
I'm not easy I started to think about
who was gonna be the winner right now I
think the front-runner is Kenichi yeah
yes I've invited that we have to see his
performance tonight for the Christopher
Brothers Forte will get a lot of votes
America loves Forte and Jimmy Rose will
get a lot about the country singing so
you can already see how close this thing
is going to be in fact last week at the
end of the night the two that we had a
vote on the two acts we had a vote on
those kids who danced and the singer
they were separated by what a half a
point how does that have a percentage
percentage half a percent we've been
through this wild journey we started way
back in February visiting cities tonight
everything else doesn't matter tonight
is where you really have to step it up
and by step it up I mean perfect turn us
on if you're a dancer there's got to be
some sort of story there's got to be
something great
it's gotta be like it's gotta be
writable because I got forbid I should
interrupt you know what happens oh yeah
no tonight is make it or break it
there are 12 of our top acts six are
going home six are the best of the best
aren't going home what you like it you
like kissing I got the background look
now you know what one kiss and he's all
flirty this finale I've been told is
like crazy they've never seen the
surprises that we have in store you know
you know Howard are you gonna perform at
the finale see now your night are you
going to you are won the prizes Mel B is
gonna prep all right no more the backup
dancers no you have never seen the likes
of what we have planned for the finale